this is a production of Cornell
University
[Applause]
thank you so much for the introduction
Michelle I've listened to a lot of
excellent seminars in this room over the
years and it's so great to have the
opportunity to speak to you here today
today I'm gonna be sharing some of my
thesis research in Michelle's lab from
the past few years and what I'm going to
be sharing is a tissue specific
molecular analysis of the relationship
between an insect vector and the
bacterial pathogen that it transmits so
the disease that I'm gonna be telling
you about today if my slides advance is
citrus greening disease which is also
known as long long ding this disease
originated in Asia and is associated
with the gram-negative bacterium Candide
Addis libera bacter AZ Atticus and for
the purposes of this talk I'm gonna be
calling that C lass actually I'm gonna
take a break to turn on my mic um can
you all hear me better now okay great
okay so I'm gonna be calling it C lass
for the purposes of this talk and you'll
notice that I have to say that the
disease is associated with C laughs
because C lass cannot be cultured and
that's also why it has to have the
candidate assassination now this is the
most significant disease of citrus
worldwide when trees are infected they
can remain asymptomatic for years
serving as a reservoir for the bacterium
so that the bacteria can be spread
between host plants within the same
Grove and then also to neighboring
groves when symptoms do appear they show
up on the fruit so the fruit they ripen
unevenly and they taste salty and bitter
ultimately the fruit drop off the tree
and within about five years this disease
is completely fatal and untreatable and
the tree looks something like this so if
you were to drive through Florida you
would see groves that could only be
described as citrus graveyards so a
control strategy for the cities is
desperately needed and the biological
players that enables us to be such a
successful pathogen are of course C last
the bacterial pathogen and C lass is
known to infect all species of citrus
importantly C lass is transmitted
between host plants by an insect vector
called the Asian citrus psyllid or the
ACP
and interestingly CLS does not exist in
a vacuum when it's inside the insects
body it actually has to interact with
the microbiota of the insect and the
main bacterial symbionts of the insect
are wool Bakke a-- carson ella and
profit ella
these are housed in a specialized organ
shown here that's called the bacterium
but as i'll show you in this talk some
of these bacteria are also found in
other organs of the insect now for this
disease to be successful these
interactions between the biological
players are finely tuned and co-evolved
and if we can disrupt these
relationships we can better stop
transmission of CLS in order to do that
we have to establish a better
understanding of the system so citrus
greening disease was first observed in
India and later China in the 1700s so
it's a very ancient disease but it
wasn't until 1998 when the ACP was first
found in Florida and then seven years
later the bacteria was detected in 2010
we learned that the ACP transmits CLS
and a circulated manner and that means
that the bacteria actually has to
circulate through the insect body in
2011 we learned that seal ass can be
found in nearly every insect organ and
in 2012
sadly seal ass was detected in
California and this really underscored
the importance of proper control
strategies for this disease and 2014 we
learned that seal ass actually
replicates within the ACP so within its
AIDS when it within the insect vector
and in 2018 we learned that not every
psyllid that feeds on an infected plant
actually becomes infected with seal ass
so si lass is not within every insect
and that means that there's some genetic
heterogeneity as to the insects ability
to acquire the bacteria into its body
and therefore if we can better
understand the underlying vector
capability we can better disrupt this
interaction so these studies altogether
paint a picture of a bacteria that
really has to interact on an intimate
and co-evolved level with it with its
insect host and the bacteria can create
an entire life cycle within the insect
so this really shows that the insect
vector is an additional host for CLS and
not just a conduit for it to move
in fact when I began my research there
was a hypothesis that seal ass and ACP
had a mutualistic relationship that they
were better together this was supported
by some key findings the first is a
study done by Kirsten Pell stilinski
that looked at the number of eggs laid
by females on infected versus healthy
trees and they found that when insects
are feeding on seal s infected trees
they actually lay more eggs indicating
that the bacteria is enhancing the
reproductive fitness of its insect
vector and the study in our lab by dr.
John Ramsay showed that insects exposed
to seal ass actually show up regulation
in specific enzymes in the TCA or citric
acid cycle which produces energy in the
mitochondria so this feeds a picture of
insects that are exposed to this
bacteria that produce more energy and
lay more eggs and that's when I came
onto this project and I entered into
Michelle's lab as part of a really
interdisciplinary grant project and the
goal of this was to go from science to
solutions for treating citrus greening
disease and we would do this by taking
basic biology and more quickly
translating it into field solutions that
can be available to growers so this
begins on the basic biology side by
doing interactome studies of the
relationship between the psyllid and
bacterium and we did this in
collaboration with Carolyn Lipsky and
Michael macaws and importantly we had so
much data from these studies we had to
properly analyze and curate this
including our genomic resources and so
we've done this in collaboration with
Lukas Mueller's lab so with all this
data in mind we would then do molecular
discovery to look for molecules that can
interdict or disrupt the relationship
between the psyllid and a bacterium and
we've done this in collaboration with
John lists and if any of these molecules
were to work we then still had a
pipeline in place to do bio assays and
delivery optimization to more quickly
translate these molecules into field
delivery and we would do this via
collaborations with Bob shatters and Ed
Stover so as part of this system we also
continuously received input from science
scientific and stakeholder advisory
boards so that we would actually be
communicating with the growers about
what they
wanted and needed all right so this
brings me to the three sections of my
talk that you're going to hear today in
the first section I'm gonna be talking
about more of the interactome studies
and this is really the discovery basis
of my research which aims at better
understanding interactions between CLS
and ACP and this is going to take the
form of tissue-specific Oh makes sense
in the second portion of my talk I'll
talk about the molecular discovery
portion of the work which aims to find
molecules that disrupt the feeding
structures of the cyllid in the third
portion of the talk I'll discuss a
collaboration with the lists lab that
develops a method to test the binding
activity of candidate molecules so first
I'm gonna begin with a discussion of
tissue specific omics but to do this I
have to tell you more about how the
process occurs when C last moves through
the insects body so baby psyllids or
nymphs feed on C last infected trees and
acquire that in the bacteria into their
bodies and then they molt through
several different stages and then the
adult looks like this and the bacteria
moves through the gut of the adult
insect and then exits into the blood or
hemolymph of the insect where it
circulates and here in the hemolymph it
can circulate until it reaches the
salivary glands of the insect and can be
spit into the next host plant this
interaction as you can imagine requires
a lot of interactions between the
bacteria and the cell membranes of the
various insect organs and so taking a
better or more detailed look at this I'm
showing you a CT scan that I've done to
show how the insects organs are arranged
within the body and so taking a holistic
view of how the bacteria has to move
through these tissues I focused on three
that are really important for
transmission to occur the first that
I've selected is the gut because that's
the first barrier to transmission and in
the first study that I'll presents I
asked the question how does the gut
respond to see less and where does see
less go within gut cells in the second
tissue I really wanted to look with dr.
John Vamsi at the hemolymph of the
insect because see less has to circulate
within this tissue and in fact it's the
immune tissue of the insect
so while I don't have time to present
this study what I've done is developed a
method to extract hemolymph from insects
and look at the proteome response to see
less in that blood tissue and what we
found is that very specific hemolymph
proteins respond to see less and we
found that male and female insects have
very different immune repertoire and the
final tissue that I'll discuss today is
the speeding parts of the psyllid so
that's called a stylet and as you can
imagine if we can disrupt feeding by the
insect at this crucial first step we can
stop transmission before we get to
interaction with these other tissues and
so in the third study that I'll talk
about I asked the question of whether we
can identify proteins that coordinate
insect feeding so to begin I am gonna
present to you a multi-omics study of
the response of the insect got to see
less and to do this I took samples of
dissected guts from insects feeding on
infected trees and remember we have to
call these see last exposed because we
don't know for sure
every gut has see less and then compared
them to dissected guts from insects
feeding on healthy trees and then to
these samples I did transcriptomics to
look at the RNA response and proteomics
to look at the protein response and
while we made a lot of really
interesting findings in this paper I'm
gonna highlight a few key things so the
first thing we found was that the
psyllid and proteome analysis really
cute us into some mitochondrial
dysfunction in the gut cells of the
insect what I mean by this is we looked
back at the TCA cycle that I showed you
before and I'll remind you that at the
whole body level the insect has an
upregulation of some key enzymes in this
crucial enzyme cycle and then at the gut
level when we map our data onto this
cycle we actually see the opposite of
fact of the gut so you'll notice that
most of these enzymes if they're
differentially expressed are down
regulated and so this clued us in to the
fact that perhaps these mitochondria are
undergoing dysfunction or breaking up
and so our collaborator tsuki amar did a
follow-up study in which he took CLS
plus here to steal s- guts and a tomato
Sox team which looks the reactive oxygen
oxygen species
by the mitochondria and interestingly he
found that guts exposed to see laughs
have a much brighter staining profile
and so this piece of cell biology
actually validates the hypothesis that
we made using an omics data set and
confirms that mitochondrial dysfunction
is occurring in the gut and these signs
are see are consistent with cell death
in the gut the second observation that I
made from this data was that there are
long non-coding RNAs or link RNAs in the
acp gut and they're responsive to the
presence of CLS this is really
fascinating because link RNAs are really
an emerging field of study and they're
poorly understood but what we do know
about them is that they are regulatory
transcriptional elements and they
respond to stresses such as package and
challenge and environmental stresses and
further look at our data actually showed
that some of the link RNAs in the cyllid
contain abundant abundant tandem repeat
elements which are derived from
transposons and this is really
fascinating and upon further literature
reviewing I found that transpose ax
Beloit's are really common in linked
rnas and they actually actively
contribute to the evolution and function
of these molecules and when I searched
our trans poseable elements I actually
found that they're homologous to those
found and confirmed in other species
finally I mapped the RNA seek reads onto
the link RNA gene and found that the
bulk of RNA reads actually aligned to
the region with transpose ax balilla
meant indicating that they're likely to
be functional in our system as they have
been found to be in others and it's
important to note that we never would
have identified these molecules had the
only done proteome analysis and then on
the converse side had we only done a
transcriptome analysis he never would
have found proteins derived from
bacteria within the gut and I'm saying
this because our podium analysis was
really a meta proteome because we're
able to look at the protein responses to
see less of both the insect but also the
endosymbiont proteins and so we
identified well bokkeum proteins in the
gut and that was exciting by itself
because we never knew that will ba kea
was actually present in the psyllids gut
and then even more strikingly we found
that every differentially expressed well
bahia protein was actually down
regulated
this is a really striking result and
what I wanted to do was see where Baba
Kia and see us could localize within the
cells and it's towards that and so to do
this I did an experiment called
fluorescent in situ hybridization or
fish which labels bacterial sequences
with fluorescent molecules so that we
can see where they go in their host
tissues and so this is a subsection of a
silicon gut that's been stained with
Daffy to label the nuclei so this should
allow you to sort of orient yourself to
where the cells are located when I use a
probe against see less we see that C
laughs adducts a striated biofilm type
staining pattern in the gut and when we
do the same protocol and stain will balk
eeeh we see that it has a much more
diffuse and punctate localization when
we merge these two images you can see
that see less and will Bakke a--
actually can occupy the same cells but
they do not coloca lies so this
indicates that there must be some sort
of co-regulation between these two
bacteria that allow them to occupy this
very same cellular space but not to
overlap or compete so this is
fascinating and to move on I actually
want to call your attention back to the
image of C less and you'll notice that
we actually see signal from C last in
the nucleus of the insect gut and this
was interesting but it's actually not
the first time that bacteria have been
observed in the nuclei of their
eukaryotic hosts in fact it's been
observed that some bacteria can invade
the nucleus of their host and then
replicate causing the nucleus to swell
and then the nucleus ultimately bursts
and causes the cell to lyse so that
bacteria can disperse more easily and in
fact when a graduate student in the HEC
lab marine a man did a nuclear study of
the cyllid gut she sees that when c lass
is present the nuclei actually do
undergo swelling and ultimately they
burst completely in support of our
hypothesis but in order to really
confirm that this is what's happening
we'd like to see intact bacterial cells
within the nucleus but even if we were
to do an electron microscopy experiment
we actually don't have an antibody that
works against C less so we have no way
to specifically label C last and see
that the bacteria we're looking at is
what we think
and so that brings me to my next slide
which is a new method that allows us to
specifically tag proteins without the
use of an antibody for use and electron
microscopy so this method takes the fish
probes which I presented to you earlier
which are made of nucleic acid and tags
the bacterial sequences and the fish
probe is conjugated with a biotin
molecule and then to that we hybridize
an anti biotin antibody containing an
immuno gold particle the immunocal
particle allows us to see where the
antibody has gone using electron
microscopy and for validation purposes
I've employed a silver enhancement stain
which chelate silver around the gold
particle to allow us to see it using
regular light microscopy when I do this
on a ciliated feeding on a healthy plant
I see virtually no staining when see
less is not present at lower and higher
magnifications and then when i do the
same protocol on a c last positive but I
see abundant staining at low
magnification and at higher
magnification I also see that the
staining adopts the same striated
biofilm phenotype that we're seeing when
we do fluorescent microscopy this shows
us that this method specifically tags C
last infected guts and that's really
promising and in a preliminary
transmitted electron microscopy
experiment
I do see a bacterial cell of this
expected shape and size of C less that's
abundantly labeled with immuno gold
particles and the immuno gold particles
are most abundant in what we believe is
the condensed DNA region so this shows
that we can specifically tag proteins or
sorry bacterial cells within eukaryotic
hosts without the use of an antibody and
this is great for the study of C last
but since these probes are so flexible
it can also be adapted to the study of
other on culturable bacteria or even
viruses and from here I want to move on
to discussing the third tissue that I've
mentioned to you today and that is the
stylet sheath so in order to feed the
silat uses a piercing sucking stylet to
pierce into plant tissue and probe until
it reaches the phloem but as its feeding
it secretes saliva that cross-links and
polymerizes to form a protective shield
Salaberry sheath around its mouth parts
and you can actually see that while
insects have been feeding on this
cross-section of a plant they leave
behind an auto fluorescent stylus sheath
that shows where the insect has been
probing and you can see that actually in
the plant these sheets undergo branching
and I'm gonna talk about that a little
bit more later and then when we look at
this sheath structure at higher
resolution you can see that they form a
linear globular structure now going into
this study we didn't know much about the
sheath but we did know that it's made of
90% carbohydrates and 10% proteins and
we also knew that it's essential for the
insect to seed so if it's polymerization
is inhibited the insect simply cannot
feed we also knew that it's
polymerization is inhibited by EDTA
which is a molecule that binds to metal
ions so my objective for this project
was to identify the proteins that are
present in this structure and when I did
proteomics on the structure strikingly I
only identified three abundant proteins
and they are al a case like multicopper
oxidases
copper oxidase and al a case and I
should note that we also identified a
fourth unknown protein which is metal
binding but that doesn't match to any
spectra in our databases and so this is
really intriguing and it might indicate
that our genomic resources need to be
improved or perhaps this protein is
heavily modified and therefore it can't
be identified with mass spectrometry but
for the rest of this section I'm gonna
focus on the abundant proteins that we
can identify which are named MCO 1 2 & 3
so I'll note that each of these proteins
has a predicted copper binding function
and therefore my hypothesis going
forward is that copper binding proteins
are involved in sheath formation the
first thing I wanted to do was to see
whether these proteins could directly
bind copper when they're in insect cells
and so working with the blizzard lab I
expressed the MCO proteins tagged with
GS gfp GST sorry in insect cells using a
baculovirus expression system I took
these insect cells and I grew them with
and without copper sulfate and then did
a Western blot on the cells to see if I
would see any difference in the protein
banding patterns and interestingly what
I see is that MC o1 forms a dimer only
in the presence of copper so this shows
us that MC o1 at least directly binds to
copper in order to form a protein
complex while I didn't see this
phenotype with M cos 2 & 3 future work
could focus on Co expressing these
proteins together to see whether they
perhaps form a heterologous complex in
the presence of copper but this
observation with MCO 1 made me confident
going forward in testing the effects of
copper on the morphology of the sheath
and so I developed an experimental
workflow that allows us to look at the
effect of treatments on sheaths and so
what I do is I take insects feeding on
plants and I add them to artificial diet
chambers containing a particular
additive that I'd like to test and this
diet is semi solid so I allow the
insects to probe on it and they leave
stylish sheaths behind I can then
collect this diet and stain it with
colloidal blue and since the Chiefs are
proteinaceous they actually stain bright
blue and this assay gives us two types
of information so first I look at the
entire diet and I use image
quantification to count the number of
sheaths that were that are deposited and
this gives us a proxy measurement for
feeding the second type of information
is morphological information because I
can use microscopy to look at any
visible effects of the treatment on the
formation or structure of the sheets now
when I do the first experiment and count
the number of sheaths put down into
diets I see that in diets containing
sucrose compared to diets containing
copper compared to diets containing zinc
there are significantly fewer sheaths
put down in diets containing zinc cells
and we believe that because zinc is also
a divalent ion it might be competing
with copper for binding sites on these
proteins and thus inhibiting sheath
formation when I do the second type of
experiment and look at the morphology of
the sheath I saw something that was
pretty interesting so in a typical diet
that doesn't contain any copper I would
see all linear globular sheaths that
have no branches but when copper is
added I see a greater frequency of
sheets containing multiple branching
structures so sometimes five and six
branches
and I observed this and I wasn't sure
what to make of it at first and then I
looked back at the picture that I showed
you at the introduction of this section
and that is this if you look at the
sheets that are deposited what you'll
see is that they undergo branching only
when they're directly in the presence of
Fullum and then take this together with
the facts that phloem actually contains
the highest concentration of copper
among any plant tissue and now my
working hypothesis is that copper
binding of these enzymes coordinates
cheese branching only in response to the
higher concentration of copper that's
found in the phloem so this is exciting
but what I really wanted to know was
whether copper treatments would affect
transmission of C last into plants and
so I did the following experiment where
I took detached citrus leaves and I
either I treated them by soaking their
petioles in either water copper or zinc
or I did a topical swab of these metal
or water treatments I validate it using
ICP mass spectrometry that both of these
treatment strategies successfully
delivers metals into the plant tissue
but I found that petiole air delivery is
the most effective so I did both of
these treatments and allowed the metal
to uptake for two days and then I added
10 C less exposed insects to each leaf
and then I allowed the insects to feed
for two days and I chose two days even
though it's relatively short amount of
time for the insects feed because I
really wanted to tease out the early
feeding driven transmission events that
we might see in a typical field setting
and see whether our treatments would
affect that so after this feeding period
I dissected the mid ribs or Center vein
of the plants and I collected the
insects then I did DNA extraction and
qpcr to detect the titer of C last
within these samples and I'll note that
the to PCR confirmed that all of these
insects contain C lasts within their
bodies and then when I did the qPCR on
the midrib the plant samples i found
that the highest level of copper treated
plants actually contain the highest
level of C less within them so this
indicates to us that copper increases C
last
transmission so to review what I've
shown you in this section I've used
proteomics to identify putative copper
binding proteins in the sheath and I've
confirmed that at least one of these
proteins binds to copper directly and
I've also shown that sheath morphology
and deposition is sensitive to copper
and zinc and that there is a branching
phenotype that we see when coppers
present and finally I show that see last
transmission is enhanced when copper is
added to the plant exogenously and this
is such an important result because
based on my personal communication with
growers copper sulfate based fungicides
are applied to organic and conventional
citrus groves roughly every two weeks so
this data indicates that our management
strategies as they are now may
inadvertently be enhancing the sellers
ability to feed and therefore transmit C
last into plants and so with that I want
to move to my next section I hope this
previous section convinced you that the
stylet sheath is a really important
structure to learn more about and
ideally to inhibit and that's what I
want to focus on for this experiment so
as I mentioned to you the goal of our
big grant was to select molecules that
would bind and inhibit psyllid function
and the molecules that I wanted to use
in collaboration with the list lab were
RNA aptamers and optimized are short
small pieces of single-stranded RNA and
they have a unique sequence in its
center that gives them a unique
secondary structure and the secondary
structure allows them to bind to targets
with affinity that's comparable to
antibodies but unlike antibodies once
the sequences are available they can be
synthesized in virtually unlimited
quantities without the use of an animal
and therefore without any batch effect
also they can be developed by a typical
molecular biologist in a wet lab they're
developed using a process called seal
acts which stands for systemic evolution
of ligands like exponential enrichment
and this process requires a large
library of RNA aptamers each of which
has a unique affinity for a target and
I'll note that the target is typically a
purified protein in the most
conventional selects experiment so this
large library is hybridized to the
target and then washing steps remove the
RNA aptamers that
stay bound and then those that do stay
bound are eluded and these eluded apt
immerse serve as the template to
resynthesize this starting library and
this process is iterative so each time
it's completed the starting library is
less diverse but has a higher affinity
for the target of interest and after the
selected number of cycles these
libraries can be sequenced to identify
the optimist that are highly enriched
against your target so when Michelle and
I first met we talked about the benefits
of RNA aptamers as they could be applied
to agriculture and this would be their
very first application agriculture so
what we talked about was that their RNA
molecules so they can be delivered
directly into trees via viral vectors
synthesized by a collaboration that we
already have in place with dr. bill
Dawson so dr. Dawson takes citrus
tristeza virus and deactivates it to
make it make it asymptomatic and he uses
it as a tool to deliver RNA directly
into trees and these viral vectors are
actually already approved for field
application in citrus and then
alternatively RNA can also be
synthesized using modified nucleotides
that increase its heat and nucleus
resistance so this type of strategy can
be evaluated for topical applications so
when I began as a first-year graduate
student I wanted to try something really
unconventional which was to use whole
tissues as Felix targets instead of
provide proteins and so the tissues that
I selected were whole gut cells
suspensions and purified Salaberry
sheets and I did this helix experiment
and sequence the libraries and I didn't
get any ab Demers that were enriched
against the gut and in light of what I
showed you about the gut rodeo in
transcriptome this is actually not
surprising in retrospect because now we
know that this tissue is so complex it
has thousands of proteins and thousands
of transcripts and it has a really
complex cell death like response to see
less so it's no wonder that this complex
tissue was not able to enrich an RNA
molecule against it but as I've shown
you the salivary sheath is a much more
homogeneous tissue with only four
proteins abundant and so we were able to
enrich one Optima against it however I
did want more optimist to test so I also
tried to express the MCO proteins as
and purify them in a more traditional
select strategy and so this actually
also proved to be a experiment with a
lot of pit bulls because these proteins
are very large and they also prove to be
toxic bacteria so I did work with the
blizzard and Chaffey labs and we tried a
lot of strategies and we're still not
giving up but we haven't purified them
yet and so what I wanted to do was focus
on the after we had and just see whether
it happened that so to do this I first
did a predicted secondary structure of
the abdomen and this is a representative
structure but I'll say that this
structure has three potentially active
stem loops and then I took the sequence
of this RNA molecule and I scrambled it
to generate a control that has the same
ratio of nucleotides but a very
different secondary structure and when I
deliver the scrambled optimal control in
artificial diets the sheaths that are
put down in the diet's look like what
you would expect they are linear and
they're globular and there are quite a
few of them but then when I do the same
experiment delivering the sheath after
mer the sheaths that are put down are
much shorter and much less abundance and
at higher magnification I see that they
also haven't fully polymerized so first
I'm showing you that there's a
morphological effect from this abdomen
on stylet sheets and then the next study
I did was just to count the number of
sheets that are put down and even
counting them morphologically deformed
sheaths
there are still fewer sheets that are
deposited in our abdomen containing diet
compared to the scrambled control and
the next thing I wanted to know was
where this after mer can go within the
psyllid organs and so I did an
experiment where I fluorescently labeled
both the scrambled and the sheep after
MERS and I delivered them to insects via
artificial diets in addition to a
control diet which just had sucrose so
next I dissected the heads to expose the
stylet and some salivary gland material
and I also isolated the salivary glands
of these insights so this is the
dissections from the control diet and it
gives us a baseline for the
autofluorescence from the cuticle and I
of the insect but you'll see that we see
virtually no fluorescence in the
salivary glands of this insect and we
don't see any fluorescence in what's
left of the salivary tissue when I
deliver the scrambled diet we see
similarly a sense
no fluorescence in the salivary glands
or in the stylet when I deliver the
sheath Optima I actually see that the
app temir localizes to the salivary
glands of the insect and at higher
magnification I can see that the Optima
enters into specific salivary gland
cells and localizes to specific puncta
which may be vesicles or organelles and
this is an interesting result and it
potentially indicates that the activity
of this app tumor may be longer-lasting
than its initial delivery if it can
accumulate in the salivary glands of the
insect so this makes me to the next
section of my talk because here we have
a candidate molecule that looks really
promising but it also presents a problem
because it was selected against an
entire tissue so how do we know what
it's binding and so that brings me to my
collaboration with the list lab in which
we developed a method
well first we address the problem of
there's no method to test whether
aptamers bind to their intended target
specifically which is insane because RNA
aptamers are used to treat human
diseases such as macular degeneration
and in this treatment protocol they're
injected into the eyeballs of human
patients but there's no method to test
that they find what we think they bind
so we took this problem and what we
would usually do in the heck lab is an
affinity purification mass spectrometry
to identify the binding target of
anything and typically affinity
purification mass spectrometry takes an
antibody specific to your protein of
interest and pulls it down from a cell
extract and it mobilizes it on PA and
then this protein plus antibodies can be
alluded from the beads and then we can
do gel electrophoresis or mass
spectrometry to identify what came down
and so we ask the question can we use
RNA aptamers instead of antibodies to
perform ap and that's experiments and to
do this I worked with Judah T ray and we
developed a strategy and this is all
done in human cells because human cell
lines have well characterized proteins
and well characterized optimized to work
with so what we did was we took human
cells expressing either free GFP or a
fusion protein of a well-studied protein
heat shock factor 1 or HS f1 with GFP
and we pulled them down using a GFP AB
de mer
and we're predicting that this pulldown
will result in meaningful interactions
so we'll identify our bait proteins as
well as any interactions and then as a
control
we used a control app tumor which should
not bind to any protein in human cells
and we're predicting that this
interaction will identify proteins that
bind to RNA non specifically and we've
made this data available for groups who
want to do affinity purification with
Optimas in the future so our
experimental workflow is this we took
the GFP and the control app Demers and
we added a poly a tail and to that we
added a poly t biotin and then we used
these in place of antibodies to pull
down their target proteins from cell
extracts that had either undergone heat
shock or had not undergone heat shock
and we did that because hsf one is known
to change its protein binding activity
upon heat shock so we should be able to
pick up this interaction using our
method so from this we're expecting to
pull down our target proteins either GFP
or the fusion and then we can do a
gentle biotin dilution to pull down our
Elliots and then to validate this method
we first did gel electrophoresis and
silver staining and when we did this the
gel that we have I'm gonna break this
down so when we do this we take non
heat-shock cells that are expressing
three GFP and when we pull them down
with the GFP Optima we actually
identified the banding size of free GFP
when we do the same with a control
Optima we don't mind GFP when we do
these experiments pulling down from
cells expressing the fusion protein we
do find the size of the fusion protein
but not in the control this pattern is
the same in cells that have undergone
heat shock but we see some differences
in the banding patterns under heat shock
and we're expecting these to be altered
interactions with hsf one that are
responsive to the stress and then when
these Elliots are excited with UV they
actually fluoresce indicating that GFP
is present and that it's in it's correct
conformation so to further validate this
method we had to proceed to mass
spectrometry to identify what proteins
were in these Elliots and the first
thing we want to know is whether we
pulled down our bait K genes and so in
non heat shock cells
a fusion protein hold down with GFP we
are identifying heat shock dr1 and this
measurement takes the number of spectra
matching to our protein and counts them
so it's a measure of protein abundance
and the fame pattern is observed when we
take heat shock cells and pull them down
with the gfp ab de mer and you'll note
that we pull down virtually none of this
protein in our control treatments the
next thing I wanted to know was whether
we had identified interacting proteins
of H s f1 and so I did a tool I used a
tool that algorithmically scores the
proteins that are identified in your
sample and gives them a probability
score for their interaction with your
protein of interest in our case H s f1
and when I do this using non heat-shock
cells we identify seven interactors and
these are predominantly published and
validated interactors which is exciting
for us because we see now that we can
recapitulate published results but when
I do this analysis on heat-shock cells
the number of interactors jumps up to
sixteen and that reflects what we
believe to be real biology upon heat
shock and in fact some of these
interactors have never been observed
before
for example histones have been thought
to be responsive to heat shock and
dependent on hsf one but this direct
interaction has never been observed
before and so this indicates to us that
not only can this pulldown strategy be
used to identify binders but it can
actually also pull basic protein complex
biology and finally HS f1 is known to
undergo phosphorylation both in heat
shock and non heat shock conditions and
we wanted to determine whether we could
detect phosphorylated spectra even
though we didn't do a phosphor cap tied
in richmond which is typically required
to identify modifications and so at the
bottom here these are all of the
phosphorylation sites that have been
published for HS f1 and i'll remind you
that these are cumulative and they're
observed in many cell lines and in our
study we find these sites on h SS 1 and
you'll notice that we identify a great
proportion of previously published sites
but we also identified two novel
phosphorylated threonine residues
and I'll end with that but I'll remind
you of what I've told you today which is
that the ACP has a tissue specific
response to see us and that studies at
the whole organismal level often obscure
information that can be really important
for us to understand transmission next I
showed you that an RNA aptamer inhibits
sheath formation and then finally I
showed you that Optima pull-downs can be
used to identify the binding targets for
RNA aptamers but also to better
understand protein biology and that's
the data that I want to show you today
but I want to take a few minutes and
acknowledge the people that were really
integral to the success of this work so
first I want to acknowledge my adviser
Michele so Michele is a phenomenal
mentor to her graduate students both
myself and her other students in the lab
her door is always open and she always
makes time to provide us feedback on
manuscripts and talks and she's always
ready and willing to discuss
experimental data and experimental
design she's also so generous about
introducing me to collaborators and
helping me establish productive
collaborations throughout the country
and she's also wonderful to hang out
with we've had a ton of fun at meetings
and on many trips and in addition she's
someone that is ideal to talk to if your
experiments aren't going how you wanted
but she's also wonderful to celebrate
when you have an experimental or work
success she's also a phenomenal athlete
and she models that for her lab members
and finally if you have not heard her
karaoke voice you are truly missing out
I also want to thank the members of the
HEC lab so first I want to thank Stacey
de Blasio she's one of the most talented
and rigorous scientists that I've ever
had the pleasure of knowing and she's
also been an ally and a friend for my
time in the lab I also want to thank
Mariko so she sat four feet from me for
five years and we're still on speaking
terms but also I'm really proud to call
her a friend and her and Dave Alexander
have really been a pillar of support for
my time here they even once drove eight
hours in one day when my flights were
all canceled and I was stranded in
Albany with 1,000 insects in tubes I
also want to thank Jenny Wilson
her friendship and her scientific rigor
I want to thank Laura and John and all
the other members of the high club for
hours of technical advice and friendship
and moral support I also want to thank
the other mentors that I've had
throughout my graduate time here I want
to thank my special committee Gary
Blizzard Josh chappie
Bob shadows and John lists and I also
want to thank mark Fuchs for being a
mentor and for making me feel welcome in
Geneva and so I think I had a really
unique experience with my committee
because I actually got to work closely
with each of my committee members and
spend a lot of hours in their lab
learning techniques from their talented
lab members and so I want to thank Jeff
Hodgson who taught me how to use
baculovirus to express proteins I want
to thank Chris Hobbs Hosford who taught
me how to purify proteins
I want to thank Judah Jeep Bay who
really pioneered the biochemical aspects
of Optima pull-downs and he was just a
wonderful collaborator and I also want
to thank Abdul Ozar
who taught me everything I know about
RNA aptamers and she was also a
wonderful friend and collaborator and
finally I want to thank the whole list
lab for really making me feel welcome
and for their scientific excellence and
for making me a part of it I also want
to thank my family for their continual
support throughout my entire educational
career a lot of them are in the audience
today so I hope that you'll have a
chance to introduce yourself after this
talk and finally um I've been involved
in a lot of graduate recruitment for
Cornell and for our department and the
question I always get asked is what's
the best part of graduate school and
what I always know and I always answer
is it's the friendships with the other
graduate students and so I want to thank
my friends here the graduate school for
making my graduate years so fun and for
being just wonderful people and
wonderful scientists
I appreciate you a lot and finally this
work was funded by the USDA nifA and by
the citrus Research Board and I'd be
happy to take any questions
[Applause]
your spine Orlando Airport
ideally defects in mitochondria that
you're seeing that's because of like
collapse of membrane potential and
electron transport or is it like a
screwing up the dynamics of the
mitochondrial network like that so you
know I don't have an accurate sense of
that I will say I did the quickest
experiment on the pH of guts that were
exposed versus unexposed to seal ass and
I found that see less exposed guts were
just touch more acidic and so I'm
guessing that that could be a result of
altered membrane transport but I don't
have a really concrete answer for that
actually polymerizing how do you take
the chemistry of these beautiful rock
cervezas are playing into regulating
yeah so my hypothesis is that the
polymerization is via a process called
genome tanning which requires oxidative
cross-linking of groups particularly
containing phenols so keen on tanning
has actually been co-opted by a lot of
pile polymer synthesis groups because
it's a really good enzymatic way to get
a gel like a bio gel and so my
hypothesis is that oxidative enzymes
potentially including the MCO proteins
are physically cross-linking
carbohydrates together and I guess I
would also note that since the structure
is mostly carbohydrates my hypothesis is
that the Optima is probably binding to a
carbohydrate oh yeah so I would taste
the most abundant in the sheath actually
which it's fascinating so this protein
we don't know what it is but it's
probably the most abundant
protein in the sheath and it's also
responsive to metals so when EDTA is
added it falls apart and it's also
incredibly low molecular weight so it's
abundant but my hypothesis is actually
that for most insect species that make a
sheath typically there's something
called the structural sheath protein and
one has never been identified for
psyllid species and I did test our
proteome against published structural
sheath proteins from Athens and there's
no homology at all so it's possible that
this small protein might be our
structural sheath protein but further
experiments might be needed to identify
it those structural sheet proteins they
you know I I can't answer that but I
will say that they are reasonably
conserved within a fish's but in inter
species phylogeny show that they're
between I'm sorry yeah so the question
from Adam is how would our n after merge
be delivered into trees so okay I think
your first question was about the viral
delivery okay so the topical application
well for certainly studies would have to
be done with that but I have with the
list lab I have successfully premised
these after MERS with fluorinated
nucleotides that make them a lot more
stable in the environment but not so
stable that they would stay around for
years so I think that's a more viable
strategy for topical application and we
also have in the same grant Network
which I talked about we have a
collaborator that works on nanoparticles
deliver small molecules but my
inclination would be to start with
just modified topical applications and
then when it comes to transgenic trees
we actually have a collaboration with
dr. ed Stover and he's an expert in
expressing transgenic ly molecules using
a phone specific promoter and my feeling
in Florida especially is that if a
transgenic treat reliably inhibited
insect feeding or was more resistant it
would be implemented because the need is
so dire and then when it comes to viral
delivery we actually have several CTV
delivery constructs in the greenhouse
now so the idea with that is that they
can generate these constructs and they
can be expressed in bud wood that can be
grafted onto a mature tree so one
potential pitfall there is that some
cultivars of citrus might be resistant
to CTV so that would be a limitation of
delivering that anyone else have
question that is yes so the question is
if you inhibit the stylet do they starve
and die is that the goal so yes that's
the goal so if you inhibit the stylet
they can't feed and they do starve I'll
note that they actually can go quite a
while without food but if they're not
feeding then that's solve our problem so
that's the goal is just if we can kill
all the systems because they are an
invasive species it's not like we would
be disrupting an ecosystem okay I think
those are all the questions so thank you
guys so much this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
cornell edu